maintenant que vous êtes prête oui
qu'est ce que c'est
quelques séquences assez de muriel ne
t'en fais pas
muriel prendre mûrir calme-toi to value
nous traduire la chanson c'est line
renaud qui chante son du crâne est
incroyable c'est une chanson dit dans
nos biens alors ça s'appelle l'interview
alerte aux roses
scheer est ce que vous avez besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour ou es ce que
vous avez besoin de faire l'amour pour
aimer le premier vous avez besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour mais je me
faisais que je changerais les hommes ils
ont besoin de faire l'amour pour m
scheer on se concentre adultère
friedrich vous trompe imaginant vous
préférez ne pas savoir où vous êtes
partisan de tout vous dire rien mais que
j'ai bien sûr le droit de le tuer
oh la la la la est ce que vous préférez
un mec qui baisent très bien décrit
infidèles ou un mec qui baisent mal mais
kevin je dirais brit air leader à l'est
de dakar
voici la première fois qu'on aurait
pensé après muriel c'est vraiment
l'esprit tordu s'avère en fait donc
pourrait avoir une femme pour s amuser
avec un homme de toute façon donc bien
sûr si c'est pour s'amuser autant à voir
l'homme qui n'est pas fidèle dans ce cas
là je n'aurai pas besoin d'être fidèle à
moi même
quel est pour vous le lieu idéal pour
une 30
le lieu idéal pour lui c'est dans une
voiture ah bon pourquoi dans l'amérique
profonde les quotas monseigneur en
carrosse
j'ai essayé mais est-ce que vous avez
schirrhein un fantasme que vous n'avez
pas encore réalisé et à moi et je crois
que j'ai toujours une idée comme tout le
monde j'ai encore un truc j'ai pas osé
faire quoi oui tout à fait et vous corée
mais les fantasmes ça va ça vient ça
change tout le temps
phobiques les réaliser sinon après ça
change de forme d'accord bien
alors maintenant cette question m'a été
envoyé par georges avec un j est ce que
vous préférez
l'amour cinq fois par jour toute votre
vie et que le même homme ou une fois par
mois toute votre vie avait quand même
différent je crois qu'elle 5 fautes en
chine mais bien alors un autre email une
question email d'arnaud si friedrich
race un rendez vous important
l'après midi et qui vient faire l'amour
avec vous vous lui dit tu es fou où tu
me rend folle
voilà eh bien je dirais oui ça me rend
folle vous les aurez pas tu es fou ouais
tiens oui oui bien que j'écris sur
l'ardoisé vinpearl ardoise sortie
schirrhein
aux échos édition
plus tôt
préval dans les souris externe